Okay.
Alright.
This is gonna be interesting.
Also, hello everyone.
Hello, Lieutenant, Deadpool, Sayori, Maple, Skulltaker,
Dylan.
Oh, who else?
Who else?
I think Redder.
Alright, hey guys.
Okay, this is gonna be interesting chat because I've never,
never played Portal before.
Oh my god.
That's funny.
Thank you so much for the, for the, oh shit.
Oh, I knew I forgot something.
I forgot to add my alert box.
Look, I told you this is scuffed, okay?
All right, okay, let me replay this.
I forgot to add my alert box.
I was like, I must be missing something, right?
I'm missing something, right?
And it's my alert box.
Can we get some bark nights real quick for S&E for the tier
one sub for five months.
Also, bark nights for lieutenant, too.
Holy shit.
Okay, I don't know if I should play music.
Do I play music in the background for this chat?
Because this is what we hear.
Like, damn.
Do I play music in the background?
I don't know if it'll, like, fuck up the immersion or
whatever.
All right, all right, all right.
New game.
Chapter one.
All right.
I've never played Portal before, so Portal soundtrack kind
of slaps.
All right.
Alright, alright guys, I guess you can backseat game, uh,
because I'll be so fucking embarrassed.
Try to figure shit out, and then I'll be like, oh, I can
play right now?
How do I pick shit up?
Can I pick shit up?
Oh, shit, I can walk.
Okay, I can jump.
Alright.
I'm learning.
Oh my god!
Hello, and, oh, again, welcome to the Aperture Science
Computer Aided Instruments Center.
Oh my god, Ramstead, can we Can we so much of the tier 1 19
ones?
And we are now ready to begin the test proper Okay, I'm just
listening real quick Can we get some work?
Can we do a quick for Ramstead?
Let's go to some class Am I zoomed in?
Oh shit, I got Why is my kid so zoomed in?
I'm so scuffed I was like Oh my god, why is this so zoomed
minute okay that makes sense I was like damn what the fuck
is wrong in my game what the fuck all right everything is
all right all right all right here we go there we go
professional streamer professional streamer is there
subtitles hello sorry I was the traffic to be a full of
Intervention.
Oh, shit.
Is that me?
Okay.
I got this, chat.
I got this.
Can I run?
Oh, is this the companion queue?
Excuse me?
Are you kidding me?
Okay, there, there.
Apparently, I am not very good at physics across the exit
this aperture science material emancipation grin will
vaporize any unauthorized equipment all right first puzzle
first puzzle's done for instance the aperture science
repeated storage cube i'm so smart i passed level one i'm
gonna see this is so sad this is so yes please clap for me
congrat you're so smart duke you're so smart wow how you did
it thank you thank you guys think i know i know i'm very
smart i'm very smart god is so embarrassing place the
weighted storage cube on the 1500 megawatt aperture science
heavy duty super colliding super button you put that cube i
know right shit who else could do that not your only me oh
okay here
oh what what oh What?
I get it!
Let me in!
Oh, okay.
Is this timed?
It's timed, right?
Oh, gotcha!
Perfect.
Please move quickly to the chamber lock as the effects of
prolonged exposure to- This is the user one reason.
Okay, it's timed.
Okay, okay, I'm slowly I'm slowly learning the mechanics.
It has to defy physics and force the camp through- I didn't-
I thought it was a glitch, okay?
I thought it was a glitch.
Is there bee hopping here?
I'm bee hopping.
Very slowly, very slowly.
Hey, Suna!
I'm trying to learn right now.
It's a...
It's like...
It is technically an FPS.
Oh shit, really?
It's not part of any test protocol.
It should already be a guide.
Oh my god!
I actually don't know how to beat hop.
I...
Oh, you're enjoying Portal?
I did!
I got past level one!
It's apparently very hard from what my chat told me.
Level one is a very hard game.
oh very good okay i got the portal done you ever played no
i've never played halfway i think i i've not played a lot of
games only to let you can pass along this game will make you
grow wrinkles all right however has not do not touch the
operational end of the device do not look directly at the
the tier three eight months under no circumstances should
move anyone okay some park nights real quick for oh my god
atlas thank you thank you for the i'm sorry i think i i i
don't know if i can help you with that i don't know if that
will help but thank you atlas for the 50 thank you so much a
beaters say thank you for actually i wanted to say that yeah
okay oh my god i'm so smart how do i oh my god i'm so smart
okay to be fair i just to be honest i just spammed i just
spammed shots until it worked i wasn't i don't know how i
did it but i did it Thank you again, Roy, for the fucking
tears they're so crazy.
And also the $50.
Dude, I didn't even think about where to shoot it.
It just happened naturally.
Welcome to test chamber four.
You're doing quite well.
You do so well.
To ensure the safe performance of all authorized activities,
do not destroy vital testing apparatus.
What is this?
Did it work?
Oh!
I thought this was it!
I thought this was the thing!
Oh my god, I'm so fucking stupid.
Please.
You broke so much so much.
This solid puzzle.
We will not monitor the next test.
You will be entirely on your own.
Good luck.
Okay.
Is this still level one?
I can't even tell.
I think right click and left click do the different portal
colors.
Oh, I just been spamming left click until it works.
I don't know what I'm doing.
Oh my god.
God, I'm so fucking smart.
Okay, where's the other one, though?
Is it this?
Oh, my God!
Holy shit!
I'm so sorry!
This is really long level one.
So we're gonna get stuck here only on level one.
It was an outright fabrication.
Good job.
Oh, good job.
As part of a required test protocol.
We will stop enhancing the truth in three.
I'm a big brain.
I am a big brain.
Huh?
Where the fuck am I?
What?
What happened?
I don't even know what happened.
What the fuck?
What the fuck happened?
If I don't even let you down require your brain power, I see
this game going so well.
What is this?
Oh!
The Aperture Science High Energy Goals.
The Aperture Science High Energy...
Okay.
Okay, okay, look.
I...
The Aperture Science High Energy Goals.
The Aperture Science High Energy Pallet, seen to the left of
the chamber, can and has caused prominent disabilities, such
as...
Uh...
Okay, look.
many enrichment center goals the aperture science high
energy palette seen to the left of the chamber can and has
caused permanent discipline oh my god i did it first try
first try also thank you so much for the follow dargo thank
you thank you thank you have a have a butter thank you so
much okay wait have a butter yeah look look look first try
first try first try uh never died once never die never die i
love you thank you so much for those five bits thank you
thank you i really do appreciate it thank you guys thank you
is that five bits for my no deaths run thank you i think i
know haven't died yet i'm still looking smart i'm pretty
good i'm pretty good at this game yeah see does he think so
pretty fucking good warning devices are required on all
mobile equipment have been found to agitate the high energy
phallus and have therefore been disabled for your safety
what what is this oh okay what's going on oh
okay she's she's lost out there program what okay it moves
Look at that.
First try.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I'm getting this.
My brain is slowly expanding.
It is getting bigger and bigger.
Oh shit, oh yeah, guys.
You saw what happened on Twitter for me, right?
Like, I was supposed to stream at 10 and then all the Gura
shit that happened.
Basically, okay, so...
Wait, let me get here.
I need to listen.
an unsatisfactory mark on your official testing record
followed by dead good luck okay so i was supposed to stream
um are you sure you fell geometry oh my god i was about
jumped out okay so what happened was that basically the
whole guru shit apparently apparently is this what i'm
supposed to do what am i supposed to do
is this is this it okay so apparently Okay, so apparently
Gura accidentally, she didn't know and she fucking...
Wait, what?
Where do I...
Where do I tick this?
Where is it going?
Where is this going?
Like this?
Where...
Where are you going?
Wait, did I do it?
Oh, no, wait, are we not?
Wait.
What is this?
Where are you?
Oh.
I...
Oh,
yeah, no, the emails got removed, basically.
But I had to, like, deal with all that shit earlier today.
What?
Wait, what?
Okay, so basically, Gura used emotes that were from an emote
artist that was tracing emotes.
So I had to like... I had... What the fuck?
I'm so fucking confused!
So I had to like... I had... I made like a whole social
media post about it, and then she got it removed in an hour
after that, which was pretty nice, because usually like, you
know, people don't react that fast.
and stuff so like my um i like i like contacted my friend
that got her emotes chased by that person so guru was using
those emotes for what the am i doing where where is it oh my
god can i can i go here where is this okay oh
I'm so confused.
Oh, oh, oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
I got this.
swear okay okay okay hey she didn't let me bring her smile
off okay okay okay like no no no oh oh i know i know i know
i know i know i know i know i know i know i know i know i
know i know i know this i know this it's right here oh my
god oh my god oh my god look look at those oh i missed i
missed i missed
I fucking missed.
I got it.
First try.
Oh, before you go for the death ball.
At the end, the light comes through the orange and bounce.
Yeah, I didn't even need to read it, Lieutenant.
I didn't even need to read it.
I might have missed, though.
I might have missed the first time.
Look.
All right, first try.
First try.
Never missed.
Never missed once.
Look at that.
My brain, my brain is so fucking big.
This is so sad.
This is so fucking sad.
Okay, but yeah, it was like a huge mess.
It was such a huge mess of the Gura thing.
And then now everyone's like trying to, everyone's trying to
like get in on the, and the whole, like, now that Gura has
like new emote slots and stuff, all the emote artists are
trying to get in on it and being like, I'm so sorry about...
How about the whole...
I saw like two emo artists doing sketches.
I don't know if he was one of them, and then there was
another one.
Uh, there was another emo artist doing sketches.
Hoping to get picked by Guru right now.
Dookie before I...
Every time I take away a slice of the cake.
It's okay.
The cake's a lie anyway.
I don't need cake.
Oh.
Oh, I was like, this is easy.
I could just take it over there.
Okay.
I'll get this.
BAM.
The enrichment center apologizes for this clearly- Oh, this
is easy!
Boom!
Why the fuck is this easier?
Why was this easier than the last level?
Fantastic.
What the fuck?
You remained resolute and resourceful in an atmosphere of
extreme pessimism.
How the fuck was this easier?
That's not fair!
Okay, okay, okay.
But yeah, I was, uh...
It was pretty chaotic.
I- I'm surprised- I'm surprised that no one, like, even,
like, uh, uh, mentioned about, like, gross traced emotes
there.
Because I- when I saw it, I was like, wait a minute, weren't
those the traced emotes from that artist earlier?
And then- and then I was like, what the- uh, it's like, it
has gross art.
Yeah, that's a big- a big opportunity, yeah.
Uh, going crazy, too?
Going crazy about what?
Yeah, this is very much about what the fuck did you say to
me?
yeah um but yeah i just couldn't believe that no one noticed
it and i was the only one that like talked about it when he
uh where he notes in the q a what is girl girl is the the
the hollow alive uh shark girl uh in the english in the
english community and like what the am i supposed to do here
oh that's what it's supposed to do that That's what it's
supposed to do.
Okay.
Where's the portal?
Oh.
Did I do it?
Is this the other side?
No, this is not the other side.
Um.
Oh, yeah, yeah, and then a guru's emotes or New emotes were
were were traced by from other twitch emot artists and she
didn't know so then I like taught like I made a Fun time fun
phone died.
Oh, yeah, so like no one What the fuck
Wait, you will how how did I do this?
What?
Wait!
How did I...
Okay, I passed the level.
I don't even need to know.
I just did it.
I don't know how the fuck I use this.
Here?
I just almost barked.
Hit empty.
MP fuck.
Okay.
Is this momentum?
Momentum.
The function of mass and velocity is conserved between
portals.
Can I do it?
You launch yourself.
You launch yourself across the...
Wait, where's the door?
Wait.
Where is it?
Oh my god, I did it.
I did it.
I just think that's how portal works, is each time you go
through, you add mass to one and take get away from the
other.
So you keep falling eventually you'll make a black hole.
I'm pretending to understand you, but...
I'm trying my best.
I'm trying my best, chat.
I'm trying...
I'm so...
Hi, I ain't gold.
I'm good.
I'm just...
How hard do you want me to control backseating?
um i think like even when i read the vaccine comments to
always provide useful advice is she giving me good advice
because i've not been listening i've not been listening at
all honestly but like i feel like even if people try to give
me back to gaming advice i still don't understand i still
wouldn't understand because i remember major was trying to i
think it was major was trying to explain to me something or
lieutenant and i read it and i was like
I don't think I'll understand even oh wait okay we don't oh
oh water bad
what the enrichment center promises to always provide useful
advice for instance
What?
For your reference, it takes people an average two hours and
three minutes to compete their game on their first try.
Oh.
But I'm not.
I hate, I hate, like, other people.
I'm not average.
What is this?
Oh, it's this.
I'm just built different.
I'm just...
Oh, no!
No!
Oh my god, I'm just built.
Well, you are built different now.
Oh my god, Zatia, thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I'm a buttern, thank you so much.
I'm just built different.
How does this even go?
Did I do it right?
Oh, I did it.
It's a sad one.
Oh, no!
No!
I thought...
I thought I was clear.
I thought I was clear after that.
Sorry, we haven't died yet.
I haven't died yet.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Is this...
Okay, all right, we got...
Where am I supposed to go?
Where?
What the...
Dookie touched the bad one?
I'm gonna post one of these bad boys every time you get
caught.
Oh my god!
Did I touch the gun?
Oh!
I was like, what do I do?
Also, I'm just...
Thank you so much for looking at the other game.
Vince, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Oh my god.
Thank you for the fine gift and sauce!
Holy shit, thank you!
I have some clats, some clats.
Woo!
Thank you, thank you, sorry.
Can we get some park nights real quick?
Can we get some park nights real quick for you, sorry?
Thank you so much.
Okay.
Alright, what do I do now?
What is this?
Excuse me.
me how do i get there how do i oh wait no no wait oh wait
wait i already i already did the portal there okay i don't
need to click it i don't need to click it okay okay we got
this we got this dude my brain is expanding my brain is
expanding look at that look at that first try first fucking
try no streamer could do first tries like me i'm glad you
i'm glad you like my lap tater i really do appreciate it
thank you oh my god this is not a two hour game this is not
this cannot be a two hour and 30 i refuse to believe this is
a two hour and 30 minute game
there's no way
there's no fucking way boom first try oh okay that's not it
that has not it wait no I did it look at that boom I did it
wait wait did I fuck up wait wait where do I go oh okay look
at that boom
I did it Oh my god, Tater Oh my god, Zara Okay, I said it
wrong Zara, thank you so much I gifted so much to Tater
Thank you, thank you Can we get some work nights real Oh my
gosh, how can I clap now?
Can we get some work nights real quick To Zara for getting
us up to Tater?
I really do appreciate it, guys I really do appreciate it I
checked it out at 2.7 hours Okay, alright So 2.7 hours is
the speed run, right?
It's the speed run It's the speed run And now, don't worry,
okay, okay.
What the fuck?
Where is this?
What is this open?
Oh,
how do I get this?
How do I
get this?
Where is it?
Did I fuck up?
I'm so confused.
Oh, she did this for you.
This is what she did.
Wait, but why?
Wait, where is it?
Where the fuck is the queue?
Where is it?
She's just stupid.
Oh my god, I'm so fucking smart.
I'm so fucking smart.
Look at that shit.
I didn't need your help anyway.
Boom.
I did it.
Let's first try.
Let's just try.
What do you all mean?
I'm not stupid.
I swear.
I'm just built different.
I'm just built different, chat.
I'm just built, exactly.
I'm just built different.
Some people are just built different.
Now that you are in control of both portals, this next test
could take a very, very long time.
If you become lightheaded from thirst, feel free to pass
out.
Okay.
See, she said it usually takes a long time, so it's fine.
It has a brain the size of Mars.
It was barely a one brain cell.
But it was too, yeah, it's, I'm just built different.
Look at that.
She said it'll take, she said it'll take a long time.
So, so that's okay.
It's supposed to take a long time.
Do I do this?
Look at that.
That's not a brain that's a tumor's proof.
My brain is full of errors to himself.
Oh, no.
Where the fuck is this?
Where's the cube?
Oh, there's the cube.
How do I get the cube?
Oh, wait, that is not the right way to aim.
Is it this?
Okay, okay, okay.
Where the fuck?
Okay, I got this.
Oh, shit.
Look at that.
Ringo burr.
Ringo.
Okay, okay, okay.
I thought you were good.
Yeah, exactly.
What do you mean?
I didn't miss.
I don't know what you're talking about.
You think I missed shots?
That was a headshot right there.
Get over there.
Oh my gosh, is this...
Wait, wait, wait.
I got this.
I know what to do.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Maybe...
Maybe I don't know what to...
Wait.
I know what to do.
Boom!
Look at that.
First try.
Why make it so...
What do you mean?
Where's my other...
Okay, okay, this is our eighth assignment.
Look at that.
See?
It's gonna go get to the last one.
We're almost straight.
Okay.
Where did I go after that?
Where's the other one?
For your own safety, do not destroy vital testing apparatus.
Wait.
Where's the other one?
I- What?
Wait, oh no!
Oh, wait.
Wait, where's the- Where's the other cube?
Oh!
Okay, how do I get out of here though?
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Left click.
Oh, I'm fucking...
Okay.
Look.
Sometimes you just build different.
There you go.
I'm just built different.
Look at that.
Wait, wait, this is the entrance way.
I walked the... I walked the wrong way.
You will be.
I walked the wrong way.
way.
I'm just a little different.
I'm sorry.
Just went backwards.
I'm sorry there was an open door.
There was an open- you go- you- everyone goes through open
doors.
Summary from success.
Okay.
Okay chat.
I swear.
Is this still level one?
Is this still fucking level one?
This cannot still be level one.
high energy gamma leaking portal technology must be informed
that they may be informed of regulatory compliance issues no
further compliance information is required or will be
provided and you are an excellent test subject see she said
i'm excellent she said i'm excellent chat there he is 90
brain if the elevator door is open there's no oh do you go
through the door everyone goes exactly everyone goes through
open doors What, you go through the closed door?
Okay.
Where the fuck am I?
Huh?
Okay, okay.
That's clearly not it.
This is fluent in sarcasm, by the way.
Well, maybe to you, but to me, I'm like her favorite test
subject.
I'm her favorite.
Okay, me, just for fun.
should put portal on the ceiling for it and move at max
speed.
I can't even run what you mean!
This is the fastest I go!
Oh, you mean bunny hop?
Do I bunny hop?
Oh, that didn't work.
I don't know if I'm doing it right.
I don't...
Here?
Oh, that was not it.
That was not it.
Okay, that was not it, okay.
That's not max speed.
How do you...
What do I do?
It'll work one day.
Okay, I give up.
Okay, this isn't clear enough.
It's clearly not this.
Oh, wait, is it?
Okay, the fucking fuck!
Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait, it's like this.
Is it like this?
Oh!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I know, I know, I know, I know, I know, my brain.
Brain expanding, brain expanding.
Wait, how did I fuck that up?
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I...
What?
Ah!
I don't know!
Oh, I can!
I know, I know, I know, I know, I know!
I know, I know, I know!
Okay, no, I don't.
I don't know.
I just...
How do I line him up better?
How?
How do I...
How do I line this up better?
Like this?
Uh-oh.
I'll get it right.
Ah!
Okay.
Oh, he's geometry's not my my strongest geometry.
I'll get a geometry.
I'm sorry.
Is this...
Is this it?
Wait, I got this, I got...
Oh my god, I almost got it, I almost got it, I almost got
it, he got it!
He got it, I'm struggling, I don't know what I'm...
Okay, now they're both up top.
Don't worry, one day we'll get there, one day.
Two, this is not a speed run, just remember, two hours is
the speed run time.
That's the speed run.
Two hours is the speed run.
We're doing the average gameplay.
The average run of the mill.
Oh, oh, I thought I did it.
I thought I did it.
I was so happy.
Please, I believe.
Why is this so hard?
Oh my god!
This is just...
This is how you forget this is just a pipe.
Wait, you need to put the port at the bottom and one of the
ceiling to progress?
Oh!
Oh
My god How did I still fuck that up?
How did I manage to fuck that up?
Oh my god Oh my god.
Oh my god I still managed to fuck that up.
How?
Please.
Please, please.
That's my creeper.
That's me.
Where does this even take me?
Oh, it's this door.
Okay, I already forgot what door was what.
How long do you think we've been here?
Three hours.
No, actually five hours.
Five hours.
I'm being... I'm being... Oh.
Well then.
Six hours.
It is always getting a portal on the floor.
It's to aim under you as you fall.
Also, all right, just flip me off.
It's where...
It's where gold?
All right, here you go, gold.
This is where you.
This is where you, gold.
Okay.
I'm bee hopping.
Okay, this goes up and down.
This goes up and down.
A-tweens!
Okay.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, okay, okay, oh, it is supposed
to go there, okay, okay, okay, all right, all right,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, going to heaven.
He saw me.
Okay, okay.
I got this.
Boom.
And then, bam.
And then, and then, boom.
Oh.
Wait, wait, wait.
I fucked up.
Wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
I fucked up.
Boom.
Wait.
Boom?
Where does it go?
What?
Is this portal 2?
Yeah, no.
This is portal 1.
Is this...
Boom!
Wait!
No!
Please.
Wrong boom.
I have to go all the way back?
Okay, wait, wait.
I need this for that.
Okay.
Okay, yeah.
Boom.
Okay, okay, okay.
Please do not have a death counter for me because you guys
don't even remember how many times I've died.
So technically I've never died Technically I've never died
chat Because you guys don't even remember So no death
counter for you Okay Okay boom
Boom Maple uses portals to To cross faster Wait no but how
can I Use portals if I'm using portals For the boom That
doesn't make sense I already put the orange So I just need
the blue, right?
No, no, that's...
No, no, no, it's zero.
Zero times, zero times.
Watch this.
That's right.
Oh my god!
So sweet.
Is it on a cute track?
Okay, wait, where do I go?
Oh, you send your previous body to...
Oh!
Look at that.
We're just trying zero deaths.
Zero deaths, zero deaths.
No one have a counter, so technically I've never died,
right?
This is so pathetic.
Fucking children get finished with games.
I think doing three child during burnout center fight.
You're not dying.
You're about to...
Out there is just moving into the new...
Exactly, exactly.
I'm not dying.
I've technically never died.
Hmm?
Hmm.
Did I do it?
Am I across?
Okay.
Dear middle curb, thank you so much for the follow.
I really do appreciate it.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Have a...
Where's my hands?
Have a blood heart.
Thank you so...
Thank you.
Oh, where's my hands?
my butt hearts where's my hands oh there it is have a butt
heart thank you thank you thank you wait how long is the
stream it's been it's been 30 minutes we've only been
streaming for 30 minutes isn't that crazy and we're like 80
percent done of this of this no no 30 minutes 30 minutes i
had to bed night chat and also thanks you thank you again
for hanging out with us i really do appreciate it we have a
good rest of the night Where the fuck am I?
In 30 minutes.
30 minutes.
Oh, oh I can go- what?
Huh?
I can't.
with me.
Sheejin, thank you so much for the tier one for two months.
Thank you sheejin, thank you.
Ooh, can we get some?
Oh my gosh, one-handed clap.
Can we get some break nights real quick for sheejin?
Where the tier one's still for two months.
Okay, okay, wait, I got this.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, I need to look at this
for a sec.
Okay, wait, I need to look at this first.
Okay, okay, okay.
No!
Wait!
Oh!
I didn't.
I was like, I didn't.
Hi, Marshall.
I'm proving to everyone that I, too, can use... Wait.
Where's the exit?
No, no, no.
This is this one.
This one.
So it shows that children under age of 13 complete portal.
waiting hours on their first waiting four hours other first
of their first playthrough that's good that's good because
i'm only on my first 30 minutes i've only been playing this
game for 30 minutes uh don't don't mind the timer don't mind
the timer twitch is bugged right now i've only been playing
portal for 30 minutes chat
i've only been playing portal for 30 minutes so so
everyone's lying to you it doesn't say 30 minutes
wait is this another area oh this is another area where the
fuck is this huh oh do i make the falling thing am i am i
trapped where's this six take it
Oh!
Boom!
Oh, it didn't work.
It didn't work.
I just started playing machine practice.
I forgot everything.
I actually never...
Okay.
Huh?
Why?
Oh, I'm here.
Oh.
Okay,
is this, right?
Oh, I had it lined up!
Certain objects may be vital to your success.
Do not destroy testing.
Yeah.
No, I got this.
Wait, what is this?
Oh, I cannot use that.
Maybe my jump?
No.
Wait.
I wonder
what friendship could be Huh?
I wish I could be more active, but glad to be on your
footing Oh, P.S.S.
Son, thank you for the tier one for 29 months.
Can we get some work, Nigel, going for P.S.
Son, thank you.
Thank you.
Yes, I got my footing.
I got this.
Wait, this is the first try.
I've only been playing this game for 30 minutes.
It's only been 30 minutes and I'm already 90% done with this
game.
Worst.
Wait, no.
No.
Do I jump like this?
Wait.
Oh.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I've only been playing this game for 30 minutes, chat.
It's only been 30 minutes.
Wait, wait, I got this.
I got- Do I- I know, I know.
I B-hop.
I B-hop here, right?
Okay, no, that's not it.
Maybe- maybe if I keep doing it.
Uh, maybe if I keep doing it.
Boom!
Uh, uh.
Check everywhere?
Wait, can I go backwards?
Wait, wait.
Oh, no, I'm trapped here.
I'm bee-hopping.
Yes, yes, this is bee-hop.
I'm fucking doing- I play FPS games.
I know how to bee-hop.
Where else can it...
What here else?
Wait, wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
I got this.
Okay, no, I don't.
No, I thought I thought I thought I got it.
I thought I thought I got it.
Wait, oh, is it here?
Wait, wait, there's instructions.
There's an, oh, there's an, wait, wait.
I got it, I got it.
I got it.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Okay, go on.
Okay.
Wait.
What?
Go-
How do I put it here?
How do I- how?
Please!
You want to place support on the- okay, okay, okay.
Boom!
Oh, my brain!
My brain expanding.
Watch!
Oh my god, what did I miss?
I actually missed.
I didn't notice.
I'm sorry, I got top 500 now.
Look, I got top 500.
Not for my brain, okay?
It was not for my brain.
It was not for my brain, okay?
Wait, wait.
Okay, okay.
turn as to your house, I go, hello, torture.
Okay, okay, wait, I need to line this up.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I got it, I got it.
I got this.
Boom!
And it...
Okay, okay, I got this.
I got this.
I...
How did I not jump?
How did you do this?
I didn't do this.
It's easy.
Even though This is in 30 minutes.
We won't even play for... How?
How do I miss the jump?
How do I miss the jump 20 times?
My plan.
Thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you.
I'm a blood heart.
Oh shit.
Where's my heart?
I'm a blood heart.
Thank you so much for the follow.
Okay, okay, just let yourself follow through it.
Okay.
I so fucked that up.
How?
watching what while they're supposed to be in class.
All right.
Ow!
Okay.
Fall through.
Oh my god!
All right.
First try.
I got it.
I first try.
It's never fucked up before.
Did I need your help?
Okay.
All right.
It goes there.
First try.
Okay.
Boom.
How do I...
I...
Boom.
Oh!
Boom!
I got this.
I just...
Oh.
Okay.
I just need to fall through like this.
And then, and I just gotta keep falling through, right?
Right?
Oh my god!
I was right!
Holy shit!
Wait, you shouldn't don't use me when we're working so far
that she can only see if there's a boom Like, I did it!
I did!
I'm learning!
I'm gaining, I'm learning.
My algorithm's getting better, chat.
We're still getting, yeah, we're still doing horror games.
We're so close.
We're like, we're like 20-something, I think.
I think I can't math, dude.
I pretty can't math right now.
I can barely fucking boom correctly.
For one time, I spent 50 minutes on a puzzle and two an odd
dude saw it was moving the box lately.
It's 200, so.
200 cells and then we'll have a scary game it's not scary
talking okay okay it goes boom boom boom so boom boom and
then boom boom boom oh wait wait a minute boom boom boom
boom boom Oh, wait.
Whoa.
Boom.
Where is this?
Wait, how do I get it straight?
I
said this way, those boots are gonna need a boot.
I'll let you my brain cell.
Thank you, Lieutenant.
I need every brain cell I can get.
right now wait where does this go it goes all right I'm
trying to angle this okay it's here this is this is the
thing this is the thing right here right here boom boom boom
boom boom okay okay okay can I put portal here no I cannot
where the What do I...
What?
Where... How does it go here?
What the fuck?
My brain!
My brain expanding!
Wait, where did it go?
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
It goes...
Right?
No, no, it's angled, it's angled.
It's angled.
This brain is...
I'm so confused.
wait wait how's this geometry do I need to know geometry for
this chat do I how did it go from here wait wait I almost
got it wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait a minute wait
how my how is this working okay okay okay Okay.
Okay, wait.
Here, and then curve, and then goes back to me, and then,
and no, that's not it, that's not it.
No, that's not it, I haven't seen.
Here?
No, wait, no.
Wait, why is this here?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, oh.
Okay, geometry, I just need to learn geometry.
I just need to learn geometry chat.
I... Geometry?
Geometry.
Yeah?
Wait!
Oh, no, that's not...
Oh, my god!
Oh!
I do!
It's like, waiting for the positive video to hit the corner
on the TV screen from this game.
It makes your brain the opposite.
And a little bit, okay, physics, okay, I just need to learn
geometry and physics, chat, I got this, it's not like I
almost spelled geometry, I just, wait, wait, wait, no, wait,
no, okay, do, here, this is, is it angled correctly, I'm
just gonna wait until it's angled, and equals angled, angles
out, okay, okay, Pythagoras theorem, I just need the
Pythagorean theorem, right?
Okay, is this angled now?
Oh, no, it's not.
Here?
I'm learning geometry!
Oh my god, did I do it?
Wait, where did it go?
Is it here?
Am I learning it?
Where does my thing go?
Here?
Oh!
I'm wondering!
I'm just going there.
Wait.
Where is it?
Oh, wait.
No, that's not it.
That's not it.
I was not...
Is it here?
I'm just doing it until it works, chat.
I'll get there.
I'll get there very quickly.
Slowly.
Okay, that's not it.
Huh?
Everybody left her?
There's a zombie zombie.
Okay.
Wait.
Is it this?
No, it's going down.
It's going.
I don't know.
Please.
How do I do this?
See?
I'm gonna
watch the whole frame.
I'm so confused, chat.
This is it?
Wait, the ball is supposed to go...
Wait!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, I forgot.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait!
Oh!
This
is it!
Wait!
No?
Also, thank you so much for the follow.
Check.
Thank you.
Thank you for the follow.
Here's the blood art.
Thank you so much.
Okay.
Here?
Oh, you did it!
Oh, I'm so sorry!
Whoa!
I'm so sorry!
I...
Oh my god, I'm so fucking sorry!
God, I didn't need any of your help.
Look at that shit!
How do I get out of here?
Wait, how do I get out?
How do I...
How do I get out?
Wait, what do I get out of here?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, I got this,
I got this, I land here, right?
And then, oh, the portal doesn't work there.
Oh, oh,
I know, I know, I know.
Boom, oh, wait.
And then, and then, and then, and then, and then, and then!
I'll get there!
I'll, you're overthinking this!
Okay, I'm overthinking this, it's simple.
It's simple geometry.
It's simple geometry chat.
She didn't get there.
Okay.
Simple geometry.
I passed math.
I got an A plus in geometry.
Look at that.
Okay.
And then look at that.
We did it.
I did it.
I did it, chat.
Wait, oh, I thought I was on this.
Now you're dead.
Okay.
Yeah, 30 minutes, this is only, wait, what?
Oh, it's okay.
Oh, don't teach me, fuck it.
I thought it was the movie.
Oh, I'm so dumb.
Hound it on.
Oh.
Thank you so much for the one vid hyper.
Thank you, thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Okay, okay, I got this.
I got this.
I...
Okay.
Okay, did you do...
Okay, look, look, chat.
Right?
Oh!
Right.
And then...
right?
Oh!
I just need to wait for this.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I got- Oh, oh, oh, oh.
I actually scared myself there.
Look, that's me.
That's me.
Okay, now I just gotta wait for this.
Look at that.
God.
Only 35 minutes have passed since I started this game.
This is like a speedrun right here.
This is a speedrun record right here right now.
Right here.
Wait, where's my portal?
Wait, what did I use?
Wait, what color?
Guys, what color was the portal?
What color was it?
I don't remember.
I don't want to wait again, chat.
What color was it, guys?
Please.
I'm streaming this game for you.
It's not orange.
Oh my god, it was orange.
It was orange!
Oh, I could have done that.
I could have done that.
Okay.
Alright.
What do I have to do?
Never trust us!
Do I go up?
Up?
Up.
do what is that oh oh okay okay okay okay okay okay okay
okay okay where's
the ray go go down yeah oh what where is it Does this open
this?
What do you open?
Oh, you have to go on the other side!
You have to go to the fucking other side!
Oh my god!
We gotta time this.
I need to keep pressing this so I...
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, please please please please no, oh no are you oh my
god
Okay, I gotta time this I need to time this perfectly.
I need to time this perfectly
Wait, where is it no please Oh, I got it.
You can donate one or all of your vital organs to Aperture
science and self-esteem learned for girls.
It's true.
I did it.
I did a chat.
Only one minute has passed since I did this level.
Only one minute.
Don't listen to Nightbot.
Like, Nightbot's lying to you.
I'm improving my algorithm.
I'm expanding my algorithm right now.
This is so sad.
There's a...
reason why we don't do variety the appropriate chamber for
this testing sequence is currently unavailable it has been
replaced with a nice fireball what more can I say I know
trigonometry geometry and every try okay oh it's the laser
guys can I move them oh I can move them oh what
Oh my god.
What do I do now?
Is this supposed to be like that?
Did I fuck it up?
Oh, it's dead.
Okay.
Okay, it's dead.
It's dead.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Vital testing apparatus destroyed.
Hi.
Yeah, it is certainly, it's 12, 21 a.m.
right now.
It's technically Wednesday right now.
Okay, okay.
Wait, wait, please, stop!
Stop, stop, stop, stop, stop.
Stop.
wait I'm safe I'm safe I'm sorry I'm safe I'm safe oh I'm
safe
there you are are you still there
please shoot yourself can they shoot yourself can they shoot
yourself can they shoot it so please I'll get a tree oh no
geometry oh no now there's double the laser now there's
double the laser we can't not shoot itself let's
dodge the bullets oh
Wait, what do I do?
Oh!
I can just go behind him.
I was trying to make it shoot itself.
I just went behind.
Oh my God.
Oh, please, please, please.
This is, oh.
Jungle, brr.
Okay.
Can I go behind here?
Oh, shit.
Am I breaking the level?
Why did the music change?
What?
Am I supposed to be here?
Did I parkour?
Hey, Raleigh.
Oh, wait, is this an Easter egg?
I have no...
What the fuck is this?
There's milk.
Can I use this to reflect people?
If I bring this out, what is she this instead?
Oh, no, no.
That doesn't work.
That other guy said, I never finished port.
Wait, where did I come from?
Oh, I came from here.
Okay.
Please.
Wait.
Can this block?
Oh, this...
Wait, no.
Wait, wait.
I thought this blocks it.
Does this block?
Does this block me?
Oh, it blocks.
It blocks it.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Please, please, please.
Oh, it does not block it.
It does not block this.
Me.
Wait, I can't even...
Please give it back to me.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Where do I do?
Did I bring...
Am I doing this over?
Good.
Okay.
Are you still there?
I'm just gonna rush.
Okay.
I'm rushing.
Oh, I did not need to bring this back to me.
I didn't need to bring this...
How do I get here?
How did I get here?
Oh.
why did i bring this here okay okay i'm just gonna rush
through what are they gonna do shoot me yeah that's right
that's right no no wait how are you how how oh i broke it
yes yeah bitch i broke it i broke it i broke it that was
planned i planned that wait do i get how much hp do i how
much HP do I have?
Okay, I just keep breaking this?
I'm just gonna keep breaking these.
Look at that.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, no, no.
He heard me.
Yeah, that's right.
That's right.
What the fuck?
I didn't just break these.
Can't pick them up?
Oh my god, I can't pick them up.
dies from a dying turn.
Okay, okay.
All I have to do is just this.
I was trying to try to knock him over earlier.
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait.
Okay, wait.
What if I use these?
What if I use these to knock them over?
Okay.
Oh, shit!
Wait, wait, wait.
No, please, please!
Please, please.
Okay, okay, okay.
And then And I use this here, like this, and then, and I'm
gonna go, I'm gonna go break this one.
And then I go break this guy, and then, and then...
This is how you do it!
And then, and then- oh my god I'm so smart!
I'm so smart!
I am so smart!
Is this really how you do it or am I just breaking the game?
Am I breaking the game right now?
This is actually...
Oh, this is actually...
Wait.
Oh,
wait!
No!
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait.
You're not supposed to...
Wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
Hi.
Oh my god, I'm so smart!
I'm so smart.
Holy shit, look at that shit.
Look at that!
Navajo collection of kids.
Oh my god.
I'm so fucking smart.
I don't need portals.
I don't need portals!
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, wait, that's not... No, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I don't need portals!
Oh.
You already do.
This is such a backward way.
Wait, is this not how you do it?
Is this how you play the game?
How else are you supposed to do this?
Wait, okay, okay.
How else am I supposed...
I wish I didn't see the...
Okay, wait.
Okay, I got...
Okay, let me, like, geometry this real quick.
Alright.
So...
So, this is looking at this way.
Alright.
How do I do this?
What?
There's one way to do it that way.
I'll just...
I'll do this.
This hasn't failed
me.
This hasn't failed me, chat.
It's not yet spelled me!
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, this might fail me.
This has not a fell!
No, no no, no, no, no, no, no.
I'm just regen HP.
No, I'm just regen HP.
Nope.
No, it didn't reach it!
It didn't reach it!
I think I'm gonna skydive behind us.
I'm gonna kill you.
I'm like, thank you so much for the follows.
deluxe one thank you thank you I'm a I'm a fun heart thank
you so much wait wait I see another companion cube I just
need another she has that she can beat portal without
portals I don't need portals look at that this is failed me
yet oh wait wait wait wait no no okay
maybe maybe it has filled me me maybe it has filled me chat
maybe maybe it has filled me but we could do this again you
can't get rid of this guy there we go look at that and then
and then and then
no no no no no no no wait wait wait wait I just need one
okay okay searching searching all right okay okay no please
please please okay all I need to do is just do you have
enough cues I read about exactly exactly I just need a cube
of walls this was my plan there you go please please please
okay okay I have like 20 20 of these I have 20 of these
cubes.
There's no way I can fuck up.
There's no way I can fuck this up.
Yeah, that's right.
That's right.
I'm thank you so much for the follow-up man.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Have a fun, heart.
Thank you so much.
Okay.
Why else would he give us 20 cubes?
There's no other way to solve this puzzle.
There's no other way to solve this!
I re- Oh, I used to believe...
No, wait, wait.
Wait, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, I'm
regenerating HP.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, it's just giving me more cubes.
Okay, there's no other way.
I refuse to believe there is another way.
Afford of Tokyo is established and responsive, alarming.
The brain has a pretty powerful look up.
And our visual is this way.
Can we please tell her?
Look at that.
You can't even see me, stupid.
You can't even see me.
I have three more.
Can't even see me.
Look at that shit.
Look at that.
I can.
Oh, I don't know where I am, huh?
Yeah, you fuck.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait.
me on gas bitch look at that okay okay I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna bait them anymore I'm not gonna bait them anymore it's
not two more okay this is it this is that is it okay okay
this hurts what do you mean Jendrick!
This, why else would they give me like two fort, seven
queues?
They gave me seven queues, Jendrick.
What the fuck am I supposed to do with them?
Huh?
Build, I'm supposed to build a fort.
What else?
I push it like this.
Oh my God.
Please.
No, wait, wait, no, no, there's one here.
There's one here!
No!
My fork!
I spent so long making the fork!
No!
How was I supposed to know there was one fork?
How was I...
How was I supposed to know there was one more?
Why are you shooting?
Okay.
Alright.
How am I gonna do it?
Oh.
Okay.
I'm not gonna make the fort again.
But I still need these cubes.
I still need these cues.
Okay, all right, all right.
Geometry, okay.
Okay, okay, wait, wait, let me...
I swear this way better, it's way better not to work.
Okay.
All right, all right.
What would you even do?
This is a game.
mechanic they gave us 20 20 cubes for a reason chat there is
a reason why they gave us 20 cubes
okay okay i'll never play the game so if i do a play like
this there's a if not a reason you're thinking that there is
a reason please
please let me just okay okay okay okay I'm trying I'm
thinking here I'm trying to think I made this for it for a
reason wait wait wait wait wait wait please wait please
please I have a for it please please I'm trying to think
here I have a for it I need to think here okay okay so okay
okay okay let me think here
are you here no wait no it's still looking at me wait wait
wait wait wait wait all right guys thank you so much for
stopping by i really do appreciate it i hope you get that
interest and if you get like a work tomorrow okay uh
Please what do I do with this fort?
Wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, is this?
Wait, wait!
The average!
No, wait, wait, wait.
I- wait, wait, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, my port!
My port!
No, no, no, no, my port!
Okay.
Okay, I got this.
I just need to slowly push this- Okay.
Okay.
I'm slowly-
That's right!
I don't know what it- Oh, look at that!
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I got this, I got- watch this, watch this.
And then...
Ah!
Yeah!
Wow!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh!
Yeah!
Look at that look at that that's accuser for a reason That's
accuser look at that look at that shit Look at that I
conquered the drones I did it I don't need no portals I have
a I have a fucking port who have fucking portals look at
that Wait, I need my cube.
I need my cube.
Wait, how do I get rid of this?
Wait a minute.
Okay, wait, I think I need portals here.
Wait, how do I get rid of this?
Oh.
I get it.
I see.
I need to do this.
Yeah!
I need no portal?
I didn't need a single portal!
Except for that one portal that I made.
Yeah, that's right.
That's right.
Look at that shit.
I didn't need a single portal.
I just want to remind you that Android Hell is a real place
where you will be sent.
This is what I mean.
Zero to Seed Run incoming.
Look at that.
I can't get that for the other ones.
I didn't need a single portal.
Look at that shit.
All I needed was the port of cubes.
You dropped the cubes on a drone?
There was literally an X?
Wait, what?
Wait, I didn't need to build a portal.
I didn't need to slowly push the cubes into them.
Yeah, but I had to see that chamber.
in this one.
Please take care of it.
My four was too strong.
Four cubes together.
There's a little morphe on the city of like a rip with some
portals.
I don't need instructions.
Who do you think you think you're talking to?
How the fuck do I get up here?
You think I need instructions?
I don't need that.
I make my own rules.
Look at that.
rolls I'm dipping it but don't think I'm watching deep chat
is to get this strong exactly I can just do this what's this
gonna do kill me the symptoms most commonly produced by
enrichment center testing are superstition actually doki
does a check roll and her destination the enrichment center
reminds you that the weighted companion cube will never
threaten to You and, in fact, cannot speak.
Let me do this.
Oh!
I do not do that.
I, in fact, do not do that.
Thank you so much for the follow, Lamal.
Boys, thank you.
Have a...
Have a butthart.
Thank you so much.
Hey, Zero.
Okay, now I'm dead.
Someone take over sending jokie curses in heaven when one of
those bad boys.
Okay.
Boo Boo streamer.
The symptoms most commonly produced by enrichment center
testing are superstition.
Perceiving inanimate objects as alive.
Oh, the enrichment center reminds you that the ancient
companion cube will never threaten to stab your hand.
Okay, I thought I thought I got the timing wrong.
I thought I got the timing right.
But it did.
It did.
It did in fact kill me.
Superstition, perceiving inanimate objects as alive and
hallucinations.
Let me time this.
The enrichment center reminds you that the way he got the
comedic timing right.
You're never present to stab you and, in fact, cannot speak.
Maybe I do this.
Okay, I just need crouch time.
Okay, okay.
Where is this?
Yeah.
Yeah!
You thought you could kill me this time?
Ouch.
Yeah, you thought you could kill me?
I'm better than you.
I'm better.
Please don't.
Please.
Please, please, please, please.
Cube solve everything.
Cube solve.
Where is it?
Okay, that's the right right now, but still.
Oh.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
All right, all right.
We gotta hit here.
Right?
Cube is meta now.
Wait.
Boom.
Oh, boom!
Oh my God, I'm so smart.
Wait, my cube!
Yeah.
Wait, what?
Wait.
Why?
Boom, boom, boom.
Oh, because there's this.
I was like, what?
Okay, where's the other cube?
Where do I get another cube?
Hello.
Where must I acquire?
Where can I acquire a second cube?
What?
Oh, cube!
Cube!
Wait, oh, okay, wait.
I was just accidenter, I'm not reinforcing those.
I get another.
Hey, have you guys heard this new intro about dokey dokey I
heard good things oh my god Wait, where's the where's the
other one How do I get up?
Oh Boom
Oh, wait, I flicked up there Ellie Eddie Wait, what's this
Wait, wait, I went backwards!
No, no!
I was here!
And it already broke my mind.
I didn't realize I just went backwards.
Wait, what do we get here?
No more booms.
I gave it.
Get
boom boom.
Wait, where do I get...
Hello?
Did you get hello?
The ideas are nonexisting.
Oh, and believe me.
Yeah.
It's already happening right now.
Right, meow.
Wait, why is there a button here?
Where did you come from?
I know, as you don't know where to play it, like, don't you
have special?
oh oh wait wait wait wait my brain my brain my brain big big
my brain big don't worry chat watch this chat watch this I
get it I get it now I get it okay I need to go back up I go
here yeah this chat and then uh They're even on a board of
mass protection.
And then...
And then I go...
Hell is a game.
If I had a Poryo gun, I would.
Okay, okay.
Bro, come over here.
Come on.
Bro.
Yeah.
That's right.
Okay.
Um...
Yeah, that was...
That was, that wasn't it.
That wasn't.
This is why I hate coming late to the incident.
Guys, is she dead?
Okay, I'm sorry I said she found the best way to play.
Wait, Jeff, do us again?
Wait, no, I don't, I don't.
Oh!
Wait, never mind.
I thought, I thought you could go through here.
I thought you could go through here.
James got poor and not cute for a reason.
Wait, wait, chat.
I have a portal gun.
I have a portal gun, chat.
I know, I know what to do now.
I know, I know.
My brain expanding, chat.
Wait, my brain.
My brain expanding.
Okay, all right.
All right.
Okay, my brain is not...
Wait.
You can put a portal there!
What?
Oh my god, wait!
Wait, wait, wait, let me double check if this works.
I need a mixture.
What the fuck?
What?
Okay, my brain expanding chat.
Okay, and then I need it.
Where do I need this?
I need it here.
Alright.
Alright, wait.
Where's my cube?
Holy shit, I'm so fucking sore.
and then I put this here and then wait boom yeah that's
right boom woo all right
look at that first try it's only been 30 minutes we've only
been playing this game for 30 minutes and we're 90% done
with this game already is that crazy chat is that i'm
looking crazy do not trust nightbot nightbot is wrong oh i
needed my cube i needed my cube sometimes my genius scares
me i know
he said now wait no no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no i i've never no no no only
only um uh 40 minutes has passed sorry i mean 40 minutes
have passed chat holy shit 40 minutes have passed and We're
already 90% done in this game.
Is that crazy?
The way his companion cube certainly brought you good luck.
However, it cannot accompany you for the rest of the test.
Oh my god, help!
Thank you so much for the fall.
Thank you, thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
I'll have a butthart.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Okay, well, you want me to burn this cube?
Yeah.
Do you think I care?
Do you think I give a fuck about this cube?
Yeah!
How do I burn it?
Excuse me?
Hello?
I said all that?
I said all that!
And you're not gonna burn the queue!
Rest assured that an independent panel of ethicists has
absolved the enrichment center, aperture science employees,
and- Didn't you care?
Burn the queue!
For the companion queue, euthanizing crossings.
Oh my god, just burn it, please!
I don't care!
Yeah!
Oh wait, did I got burned?
What the fuck?
Did it burn me?
Why would it burn the cube?
Oh.
Your companion cube cannot accompany you through the rest of
the test.
If it could talk and the enrichment center takes this
opportunity to remind you that it cannot, it would tell you
to go on without it because it would rather die in a fire
than become a weapon.
Yeah, you think I- Whoa!
What the?
No!
You did it more quickly than any test subject on record.
Congratulations.
Look, I thought...
I wasn't thinking.
Okay, okay, I wasn't thinking.
I have to do this again!
It doesn't...
Yeah, I'm breeding you twice now after that.
Yeah, you just...
to get burned twice.
Now this dude is like, yeah.
You know what?
Yeah, this deserves to get burned twice.
Make it... Ah!
Okay.
Alright.
Are you...
Dude!
Okay, okay, okay.
Alright.
I'm just gonna put you here?
Putting you here.
Okay.
It's too big to hold.
to let it go all right all right it's round two round two of
ruining the cube you did it round two companion cube
certainly brought you good luck all right however it cannot
accompany you for the rest of the test all right cube i
already said my goodbyes bye i don't give a I think I care.
No remorse.
It killed me!
Why the fuck would I give a shit after that?
The experiment is nearing its conclusion.
Wait, there's instructions.
It's required to remind you that you will be back.
No, no, you jumped in there, my dude.
Cube.
I thought, okay, to be honest, I thought the lava thingy,
like, there was, like, an invisible wall, so I wouldn't go
down there, and the cube would.
I didn't think when you jump in with it, you die with it, I
thought it would just take the cube.
Okay.
Cube.
Hit.
Top 10 added enemy trails.
bad.
Portal jump.
Portal drone.
Okay.
What's this?
Can I go here?
All employees must wash their hands.
Oh, wait, is there more here?
What is this point?
What?
What is the point of this?
Oh, no, no!
The experiment is nearing its conclusion.
The enrichment center is required to remind you that you
will be baked, and then there will be cake.
Okay, um, anyway, this is his first try.
Alright, we just don't go over here anymore.
We just...
That never existed.
What?
Nothing happened?
Oh!
Oh my god!
I didn't know you could do that.
Where am I?
A rainbow chest.
Please, please look up where I'm at.
No, I came from here.
Oh, there's...
Oh, wait.
Where am I?
Wait.
Huh?
Walk?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No?
Walk?
What?
Wait, how do I get here?
Wait, where the fuck's the cube?
Huh?
Cube?
Oh, walk.
Wow.
Wait, no, I'm back here.
Wait.
Wait, I'm back.
Oh, oh.
Cube?
Cube Coon is dead?
No, what the fuck?
How do I get this?
What?
Okay, there has to be a cube here somewhere.
Where's the cube?
Wait, wait, wait, where's the cube?
A box!
box but walk in cube
I'm so confused I took his cape and I'm gonna walk in cube
bro cube it's gone my dude why did you guys make me burn the
cube I'm like, you're loud, thank you, Catgirl.
I, where the fuck is the cube?
Is I here?
Cube?
What the fuck?
Wait, where do I go?
Okay, okay, we do this again.
Okay.
Okay, I don't know how I fucked that up.
What?
You guys saw that?
They're looking for a mother cube.
Like, no one ever saw you live so far here.
Thank you, cat girl.
Okay.
Here you go.
Why is there a two here?
Three.
Cube.
Wait.
What color?
What color was this?
Oh.
Ah.
I don't need no cube.
Wait, what's this?
Okay, what the fuck is this?
Make sure this is done.
Make sure you keep putting her brain to the test.
Is she finally bobbing some sproom for being this?
Okay.
No, no, no, no.
Please, please.
Cue, cue, cue, cue, cue, cue, cue, cue.
Yo, thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you, thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
I have a butter.
Thank you so much.
No thoughts only, Q.
Where does this go?
What?
Wait, Q!
Wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Okay.
Okay, I need Q.
I need cube and and oh my god wait wait how do you do what
the fuck is this what the fuck is this okay portal portal
I'm just gonna keep pressing this until I processed this
correctly.
Okay, so this goes...
And then...
Boom.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait.
Boom.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Boom.
It goes through here.
Oh!
What?
No, no, no, no, no.
Let me in.
Please.
No, no, no, no.
It does...
Wait!
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Wait.
Okay.
I got this.
Okay, I just need to keep pressing this.
Okay.
And then I do this, right?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no.
They're just evolving once more.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Does it reset?
Does this reset?
Oh my god, this resets!
What the fuck do we do here?
I should learn, but it's about your art.
You drew a lot of dogs, but you can't draw cats?
Yeah, I've done lots of cats before too.
I did a lot of cat emotes, just we've been, we just drew a
lot of dogs.
In the past past few commissions.
Also I'm trying to process this chat my I'm trying to
process rethinking What up re rethinking Rethinking
Rethinking okay brain broke no no brain think brain think
brain think I'm just trying to okay so okay okay okay okay
is this working is it working is it working did it work what
oh Oh!
Brain!
Brain updating to iOS 14.
I'm in here for five minutes and you're already one of my
favorite series.
What the fuck?
Your power is so entertaining.
Brain think.
How?
Here?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh.
Wait, where did it go?
Please.
I don't understand there's too many things here.
There's way too many things here.
processes please too many things okay okay okay okay what if
I destroy this okay okay wait is it destroying this is wait
did my game crash okay brain did it Brain did it.
I did it.
I was so scared by GameCraft.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay.
Wait.
Brain did it?
Oh.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I understand.
I understand now, chat.
I understand it.
Okay.
I need to kill this.
I need to kill this, so...
So this...
This needs to hit...
This needs to hit this, right?
No!
Please!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Brain did it!
Oh!
Bring did it.
Bring, oh wait.
Wait, how do I kill this?
Wait, how do I, how do Bring kill this?
And the turret's a good chopper.
Bring going over, I tried to control both of the portals,
but we added cubes to the mix.
Okay, wait.
Chat, chat, chat, chat, chat.
Chat, chat, chat.
Bring's gonna do it.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Wait, how do I kill this?
Wait.
here where the fuck is that okay where are you pointing at
where oh oh brain oh
brain did it god i'm so fucking smart it only took me one
minute chat i figured it out and it all it took was one
minute.
One minute.
Look at that.
It's like a speed run.
Okay, okay.
Look at that.
You can't remember when you were afraid to third person.
This is alarming.
Actual game, man.
Okay, if I like...
Do I have to keep clicking this or will it never?
Will it like...
Okay, now I need to destroy it.
Okay, I need to...
I need to click clicking this or okay oh
my god let me back in let me back in i'm so scared okay i i
did it oh my gosh no no how do i okay do i need like forever
click this or am i gonna be stuck i'm bringing it i do i
need to always click this or will i always will i be stuck
forever will i be stuck forever i don't click it phone dying
at three percent all right siri thanks siri's sticking by
with us and watching watching my breed thank you so much i
hope you god i hope you have a good rest of the day this is
what twitter is like getting lost in holes the moment you
jump in it's the real porous can't be a moment here so we
pay one it wouldn't form it when it deletes okay all right
am i gonna be stuck here forever Am I gonna be...
Okay.
Brain thinking.
Brain think.
Oh, am I gonna be...
Did I fuck up?
Wait, did I fuck up?
Oh, no, no, no, no.
I did not fuck up.
It's here.
Brain here.
Okay.
okay what's over here okay nothing okay okay brain think
wait did i fuck up chat did i how do i get back inside wait
don't wait chat did i fuck up am i supposed to not have it
closed I don't know...
Oh no no I didn't.
No no no.
No I didn't fuck up.
No, no no no.
No no no no!
No no no?
Breathe.
Wait.
Oh!
Breathe!
okay okay i think i fucked up i think i think this needs to
reno work okay i got it i got it i know i know what to do i
know i used the wrong portal i used the wrong one
rain sad rain sad i'm I think I need to die again, right?
I don't know.
This is a brain burn.
I just, I'm grinning really.
I'm enjoying the burn moment.
Brain burn.
Okay, wait, wait, wait, okay, okay, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Hey, I'm sorry.
Okay, okay.
Brain, brain, brain!
Brain!
Brain.
Brain did it.
Yeah, you guys first try first fucking try no, no
Oh my god Are you no
Okay All right, I got this first try bam there we go there
You're keeping up at 4 in the morning.
There we go.
Okay.
Cube.
We got our cube back.
Okay, I'm going to put this guy over here.
I'm going to jump over here.
Wait, how did I press that?
Poor y'all.
Huh?
Oh.
portal um look at that first fucking try what
first fucking try what huh oh
the brain's with okay okay this is your brain on maple it's
not over till it's over over.
What the fuck is this?
Portal.
No!
Okay.
That was not the right portal.
Right.
It's like I've been sleeping.
It's where I am.
I'm so wide awake.
I have just five minutes of joy.
in.
I'm having a stroke after that one.
Okay, look.
Oh, portal!
This one!
And then he's like, oh shit, I don't know why this one is
just plain sad.
Not sad.
I think I fucked up.
I think I fucked it up.
Wait, how do I get out of here?
Oh, here, here, here.
Okay, okay, okay.
No, no, no, no, no, no!
No!
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Portal.
Huh?
Oh, there's a- Oh my god.
Wait, get me out!
Okay, okay.
Okay, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no.
No no no, no, no.
Okay, okay, okay.
Alright, alright, alright, I got this.
Portal?
Oh wait, wait, wait.
No, no, no.
We got this.
Portal.
Oh wait, wait, wait, no no, no, we got this!
Oh, I fucked it up.
I fucked it up.
I fucked it up still.
I needed to be high.
Wait, I need to be high!
Really?
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, portal.
Okay, I ate blue.
Portal.
Where?
Portal, where?
Portal.
God,
thank you, damn it.
I'm a fucking caveman.
Oh, I'm just saying it's portal and portal where?
Oh
Sorry when you tell your kids you become gamers Okay, okay
Okay, portal strong Portals together strong Okay, I just
remember not to don't use right click Portal
Portal.
Portal, no.
Okay.
Okay, I just, okay.
Don't use...
Do not use left click.
Portals to get it strong.
Who is shooting the portal that you need on your way down?
Portal, no, portal.
Portal.
Ha-ha!
Portal?
No!
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Don't use blue.
I know my colors.
Yeah!
Well, well, Look at that!
Look!
She said well done!
The last is still gone.
Please attend an enrichment center.
Cato thinks I did great!
I did amazing!
I got an A plus.
Or glados.
Wordle's strong.
Boringa.
Welcome to the final test.
Oh my god.
Final test.
Boringa good.
Okay.
Use consent for regulations.
Require both hands to be empty.
Hit.
Fall.
Bad.
Wash hands.
Kick.
Okay.
So.
Hit.
Fall.
Okay.
This is bad.
Wait.
Hit fall?
Hit fall.
Okay.
We're hit though.
We're hit.
Here?
Where does this go?
What?
Wait.
Where does this go?
Oh, here.
Okay.
okay hit hit hit
wait wait it moved how did I get this to move wait I somehow
I don't even know how I got this one right what I don't How
did I activate this?
Wait, I activated it!
Wait, how?
How did I even activate this?
Okay, I actually don't know how I did that.
I don't know how that worked.
Look, he has the biggest brain.
I didn't even know how I did it.
So I just solved it unconsciously.
Alright, where's the thing?
I thought I'd see your brain there, but she didn't like...
Okay.
Brain.
Please.
Oh, oh, oh, brain rig!
Brain big!
Oh?
Wait!
Okay.
Okay, brain mainly not big.
I'm loving you so much, I've been a lot of friends.
Big brain too big brain god brain god No, no, no, not again.
No,
okay.
Okay.
Sorry.
I got jump scared by by the thing Great, what do I do here?
What do I do?
Brain Brain wait, what's this?
Wait, what?
Where am I?
At least you touched it.
Green here.
Wait.
What?
I'm so confused.
I just keep going back to this thing.
Brain?
Brain!
Congratulations!
The test is now over.
All efforts and technologies remain safely, optically
optional, up to 4,000 degrees Wait, I die?
I die?
Thank you for participating.
Thank you for participating in this ever-ending event.
which are science computer-aided enrichment activity.
Goodbye?
What?
Oh.
Oh, wait.
Okay.
To be fair, I...
Oh, fuck!
Oh, dude.
Fuck you.
I don't understand.
Damn it!
Where is it?
Where is the exit?
Oh!
It's right here.
Oh, it's not- Hey, it's right here.
I thought the exit was all the way back there.
That was police.
All right, get me out of here.
Get me out of here.
in honor of your tremendous success.
Look at that 30, see, look at that.
This game only took me, so it only took me 30 minutes chat.
Only took me 30 minutes.
Oh my god, Tita, thank you so much for the 100 minutes.
Thank you, thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
Ordo, no.
Ordo, bad.
Open the door.
Ordo, ordo, bad three.
Lesson.
Wait.
Up?
No.
He's cheating.
wait huh oh
yeah i was learning about the zero the rest of the game is
like it helps me think okay less words helps me think this
game too big for me even to watch a pet sim okay no no no i
became a caveman
yeah that's right She's evolving just backwards.
Which way?
Left or right?
Does it matter?
Does it matter which way I go, chat?
Left, bugabugah, streamer, or right?
Wait.
All three?
Okay.
It doesn't matter.
She's still a bit faster.
Oh.
Look at that.
Look at that!
Ungo- Un-un-g- Oh, um- Imagine just move.
Okay, where did I come from?
Okay, I came from here.
Okay.
Okay, I go in.
How goes the portals?
We're almost atlas.
We did advancing my back.
Man, imagine, don't keep laying down today, Sire!
Okay.
No.
Wait, where?
Here?
No.
Up.
This is looking good that where she was gonna be pure goat.
Wait, no.
Okay.
Down.
Wait, wait.
Wait.
Where am I?
I was going up!
That's where he's going!
Over time!
Up?
Up.
Where am I?
Wait, oh god, go up!
He's going right!
Down.
Oh, down!
Not down.
Death.
Oh.
Up, down.
Where?
Wait.
Oh, where do I go?
How do I get out of here?
He got it.
now oh not down not down she'll go collect this right now
where the okay okay okay what's that what's that oh they're
the cubes she must have to leave because of okay okay okay
we have to go this door here
Okay, not that, clearly not that.
Oh!
Oh my god!
That's all I had to do!
Up!
It was up!
Pull the bridge out of kids!
Up, up, down.
It was up.
Was it even a puzzle?
Oh shit, it's the PS5.
Chat, look at that.
The PS5.
Look at it here.
Okay.
No, I like when I'm back now that she's saying wait all the
time.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, do I break this?
What do I do?
Wait, up?
No.
No up.
Oh, wait.
Door.
Okay.
Door?
Break?
Did I do a ton of these things?
I don't know what I'm doing.
Chairs now down.
Am I stuck?
I'm in this door.
I'll tell you.
Where do we go?
I opened all the doors.
What does he want me to do?
You seem a bit odd tonight.
Oh my god, sorry.
Sorry my brain.
I'm trying.
I don't know what's going.
on anyone okay I went through two doors oh wait where's door
for this where's the door for this oh there's there's
another way
there's the other okay but it's been so long trying to open
this door I thought I just thought we had to go this way I
hear some of all that thinking Does it seem like Tokyo's
Isabel?
He doking me for a goal Okay Okay Where are we?
Alright Oh Also thank you so much for the follow No, Billy
Thank you Thank you, thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
I love butthurt.
Thank you so much.
Your brain has overclocked too much already in the start
circuit.
That's some of the room are all stored.
Dude, I can barely fucking process.
I can barely process what's going on right now, let alone
the story.
I can barely process shit.
shit let's see how much i can push her radius thermal
throttling where the fuck am i oh oh oh
oh oh oh girl mac hush what no oh cool oh down down
Down Pog!
How are you doing?
You haven't escaped!
It's actually broken the beat!
Wait, I was right!
We were right!
Is anyone there?
It's down!
Oh shit!
Hey.
Do you really just enter Monkey Ring Road up?
Down!
Where the fuck am I?
What?
Oh, down Okay, the test is over You're welcome I guess for
your cake Wait, it was a fun test and we're all impressed at
how much you want.
Okay, okay.
We got a test is over.
Come back Oh
Oh Oh my god.
Man, I'm so cute.
You're the only one of the first muscles you've ever did.
Look.
Look, I'm a mess right now.
I'm a mess.
I'm looking.
mess right now okay oh
door oh no door door no door oh oh wait wait wait wait no no
they're like watching what the art it looks like here's dvp
turning look my my brain move my brain move fast My brain,
brain move, good job, Donkey.
Ruby, hey, you so much other than, you're the tier one, tier
one, tier one streak.
Woo, can we have some barricades real quick for Ruby?
Okay, where did I come from?
Wait, where did I come from?
Oh, here, here, here, okay.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I move up, up, down.
Oh my god, Atlas!
Thank you for gifting a sub to Elstar!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
I really do appreciate it!
Woo!
Can we get some work nights also for Atlas for gifting a sub
to Elstar?
Thank you so much!
Okay, that's the most words I've ever spoken since I started
this game.
That is that is the most words I've spoken tonight chat
Wait, how how go up?
No way way way way way oh No, wait, wait Now we're just oh
there he is peep Hello
How Oh!
Oh!
I'm so sorry!
Yeah!
Oh no, no.
Oh no.
Look at that chat.
Wait.
As
you go back.
The joy of hearing things out.
Oh!
Wait, where do I go?
Oh my god, Sire!
Holy shit!
Sire!
Thank you so much for giving me five subs!
Oh my god!
Thank you, thank you!
Can we get some bird nights real quick for Sire?
Thank you, everyone!
Oh my god, thank you guys so much.
I really, I really appreciate you guys.
I don't, thank you guys.
My brain is going 200 miles per hour right now.
Thank you so much for, for, for enabling my brain.
Thank you, Sigh.
Wait.
Where do you think you're going?
Because I don't think you're going.
use on the brute wait here here where i'm gonna go for the
night that was nice to you don't bring your brain out all
right alice thanks for hanging out with us thank you i
really do appreciate it door no no door portal no portal
ruby thank you for the one bit thank you Oh my god, Zarr!
Another party gives it some!
Thank you guys!
Thank you!
I really do- Can we get some- And- and look like the Hebrew
continuing the gift sub from Zarr?
Thank you guys!
Can we get some break nights real quick?
For- for Zarr too.
Oh my god!
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Brain- Brain go burr right here.
Wait, where did I come from?
Huh?
Oh, here!
Here.
Yeah.
Oh, that's not a jump.
Oh, my God, Rumi!
Thank you for the 500 bits!
Holy shit, guys.
Thank you.
Are we, like, nearing the end?
Oh, my gosh.
Look at it.
The cake is alive.
There it is.
He set the thing.
Oh, my God.
That is why I get this.
this up holy shit guys oh my god and duty 100 bits too thank
you chat and another oh my god guys and shayjin also gifting
a tier one you guys are amazing holy shit the brain is it's
okay it's okay i really appreciate all the support guys.
Holy shit, look at all these gift and sales.
Can we get some more work?
Nice for everyone.
Chijan and Lucklad and sorry for gifting more sales.
Thank you.
Holy shit.
You guys are crazy.
Holy, this is the most I've ever said.
These were the most words I've ever said in a minute chat.
I just want you guys to know that.
This is the most fucking words I've ever said in a minute.
portal what the fuck holy wait I think I think we're 200 now
gifting sire sire again Jesus guys she has evolved she can
use language now I I can words thank you thank you everyone
thank you thank you for hitting oh my god ah rich to the
prime holy shit I think we have the spooky stream I think
this I think we got the spooky stream Galaxy Rage she can't
word word good word good she had fast fast portal I'm pretty
sure I just need to I just need to like refresh also J-Pro
Monkey and Parsi thank you so much for the follows thank you
guys thank you so much here's some blood hearts chat we have
okay we're just gonna wave okay where am i where am i though
oh up no not up yeah give the subs do count give the subs do
count they do they do holy shit guys we're down no no no not
down get the whole all right like our sub goal which was 200
subs I think we hit it I think we did so basically blah so
basically is you guys choose you guys basically choose what
we what spooky game I'm playing so I'm gonna make a poll I
think they'll be in my discord we're gonna vote in my
discord so you guys are not in my discord yet it's
exclamation point discord to join it and we're gonna do a
little poll there for you guys to choose the spooky game
that I'll play.
And it's not going to be just a one stream thing.
It'll be like multiple streams until either I finish it or I
say fuck you guys and stop playing.
Oh no, thank you so much for the follow, I know.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I really do appreciate.
Jesus Christ, how about butter?
I honestly didn't think variety stream.
People would like my variety stream because it's the first
time I've done a variety stream.
And I didn't think you guys would like, oh, wait.
up up up you see that up I'm so happy you guys like my
variety stream because like I didn't know I didn't know I've
never done a variety stream before and like I was so scared
that you like people won't like it so I'm really happy that
people are enjoying this I'm enjoying joining my big brain
my ginormous brain up ha ha ha Wait.
Uh?
Wait.
No, that's an incredible stream.
I'm really happy you guys are enjoying.
Brain.
Wait.
Up.
Oh.
Never tell yourself.
I'm glad you guys are having a good time.
Brain, brain, working.
Oh my God, we got our level five Halloween peoples.
What did you guys get?
Choo-choo, green choo-choo.
Okay.
Choo-choo.
How do we get up there?
What the fuck?
Wait.
Up?
No feet today.
No feet today, chat.
Here?
We went back.
Okay, okay.
Oh, wait, where's my portal?
Oh, oh, wait, wait, wait.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
What color was it?
I don't remember.
Chat.
What color was that portal chat?
Okay, orange.
Orange.
Oh, I did it.
It was orange.
Did I do it?
Did I?
This is it?
Oh!
Wait.
And then I was off.
We pretend if we were going to murder you.
Maybe we're slowly expanding.
Is anyone there?
Maybe if I...
Me?
Oh!
Up!
Okay.
Every time I just...
It's just up.
It's just up chat.
It's just very slowly.
It's just up.
Wait, where the fuck?
No!
It was not up.
My mom did they meet me back later.
Alright, CJ, let me have a good dinner.
I know, we have a good dinner.
It wasn't up.
okay wait okay okay up okay i need to time this i need it i
need a time up i i oh oh oh i know i know i know i know stop
up well on the upside you know what what what what I forgot
to put a portal!
I forgot to put the portal!
I- I forgot to put the portal!
Okay.
This is- Okay.
Right.
There you go.
I am facing it.
I am.
Yeah.
Oh, oh, oh.
Please let me through.
Please let me.
No, wait.
Wait, no, no, no.
How do I do this?
How do I?
Okay.
Wait.
I'm so confused.
Is it not?
Is it?
What?
How is this going?
Help!
Ow!
Angles!
Okay, okay, geometry.
It's simple geometry.
It's geometry.
I got this.
It's just geometry, right?
It's just geometry.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh!
How am I fucking, I kept fucking up.
I'm fucking up.
Up, up, up, up.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, I did it.
I did it.
Sire, now there's two.
Give that so subterbinal at all.
Thank you, Sire.
Oh, okay, so are Park Night.
Sire, thank you for the crazy support.
43 gift subs, holy shit.
Sire, thank you so much.
I really, really do appreciate this.
Okay.
Thank you so much.
Hey, brain.
Brain.
Ah!
I can't...
Okay, okay, okay.
Ha ha!
Oh?
What?
Oh!
Wait.
Up.
Oh, I'm so smart!
Look at that.
Oh, never mind.
I'm trapped here.
I was like, I was so happy.
I was so...
It's locked.
The door's locked.
It's empty.
Are you a zombie?
No door.
Wait.
Where?
Is this a thousand times funnier when drunk?
Uh?
Oh?
Oh!
Boom!
Oh, I fucking can't aim!
I can't aim!
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, I got
this, I got this chat.
God fucking!
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Grab this.
Boom!
And then, okay, okay, okay, okay.
It's here.
Okay.
Wait.
It's like this, right?
And then, okay.
Wait.
It's right here.
It's like this, right?
And then...
Okay, okay, okay, it's like this, right?
Whoa!
No!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
wait, wait, wait, wait, okay, it's like this, right, and
then, okay, it's like this, right, and then, okay, it's like
this, and then, okay, it's like this, and then, okay, it's
like this, and then, okay, it's like this, and then, okay,
it's like this, and then, okay, okay, Okay, it's like this
right and then and then okay.
Okay, we got it.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, it's like this, right?
We did it.
Oh, yes.
Yes, so key Simple really yes, it's like that It's like that
It was like that chat First try First try
I'm not angry.
Just go back to the testing area What what how did what
excuse me?
What the fuck
What the fuck I didn't really shouldn't be here You really
did too cold.
Yeah, I I I Yeah, you're right.
I don't know about you.
I don't know what happened there.
Bro.
Rebacking.
He leaps.
It was okay.
Why are there so many things here?
Why are there so many?
Which one's the right one?
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay,
okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, we're back
here, we're back here, okay, okay, all right, nope, not yet,
not yet, okay, okay, okay, okay, we're back here, we're back
here, okay, okay, all right, nope, not yet, not yet, okay,
okay, okay, one of you guys, guys will be the right one.
Wait, this is orange.
Orange.
Okay.
No.
What?
Where?
How?
Wait.
Did I fuck up?
No!
I fucked.
Oh, wait, wait.
Oh!
Am I in the right way?
Wait, where am I?
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Um, do they work?
Oh.
Okay.
We got this.
Yeah, up?
Where do I go?
Wait, do I actually go?
Oh, no, no, no, down.
Down?
Oh, we go down.
Oh, Jeff.
My BF just became a semi-VTuber, and they grew up so fast.
Hey, Daryl, what a beat.
Thank you so much for the tier 1 stuff.
For five months.
You need some for Unite 2 and quick for Wolfie?
Thank you so much for the ranking tier 1.
Thank you.
That's so cool, though.
That's really cool.
Okay.
How do I?
How does one...
How...
Jump?
Oh.
Jump here.
No, don't jump!
Don't jump!
Oh
my god.
Ruby, can I get these up to the park night?
Can we get some party night?
Can we get some party night too quick?
We're Ruby.
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
And also, also, thank you so much, Fluffy, for the five
bits.
Thank you, thank you, guys.
Wait, where the fuck was I?
Okay, all right, we got this.
We got this.
Brain, brain, brain, brain upgrade.
Brain upgrade.
Okay, here, here.
All right, all right, we gotta wait until this thing goes
down.
And then, bam!
Look at that.
Please try.
No deaths.
Look, I'm even bunny hopping right now to prove to you guys.
Open.
No open.
Bright Knight is a bright knight perfectly balances all
things should be Oh my god Is this another rat Oh this is
like another The rat thingy Okay All we have to do Just go
through here What what what Okay Okay okay okay
Wait Wait wait I don't have cubes I don't have cubes Wait
Wait, wait, wait, wait, I don't have cubes.
Oh!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, you thought, you thought you were
better?
I don't need cubes!
Where's the second one?
I don't need cubes or this?
Oh, I don't need cubes.
I don't need cubes.
Wait, wait, where's the third one?
Where's the third one?
Wait, I don't need...
I don't need cubes.
Wait, wait, wait.
Are you hitting me?
Oh!
No!
That's how you do it.
It keeps over portal guns.
That's how you do it, chat.
That's how you kill- You don't need portals.
You don't need portals.
Also, thank you so much for the follow, Adi.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Have a butter.
Thank you.
You don't need portals.
Okay, how do you get out of here, though?
Oh.
Huh?
Oh, am I stuck?
Am I- am I stuck?
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, okay.
I got, okay, I got stuck there.
Okay.
Oh!
Okay, not up.
Not up.
Okay, it was not up.
Where's up?
Oh, oh.
It is up!
We're up!
Hey, Cypher!
Up where?
Up is up!
But where?
We're up more like score!
But I just walked into, look up!
Okay.
Okay, one of these will hit up at the grabber.
There was a sign.
There was a sign Caution Oh Up Wait Up Up Up
Up Up Up
You're not a person, you know that's right Don't end up
here.
Can you hear me?
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, imagine you're seeing this out of context.
Okay.
Okay, oh no.
Oh no.
Wait.
Okay.
There is no condos.
I'm here condos.
I'm so, don't even.
Okay.
Clearly, I don't know how to jump either.
Alright.
I came here out of context.
I was lost as fuck.
I used the portal!
This is the first time I've used the portal for these guys.
How many of you came here and say, cute, cute, and call it
me, cat girl.
This is the first time we used a fucking portal for these
things because we have no we don't have a cube We don't have
cube no cube.
What the fuck?
Oh
Oh, no cube no cube.
We actually have to over here.
Oh my god.
There's instructions There's instructions
What okay, okay, that was not that was not a good
instruction Oh wait, is he pointing up?
Is he Improvised, adept, and overcome?
Oh!
Oh, he was pointing at this!
I was like Up or forward.
I thought he was talking about forward.
I was like, what do you mean?
What do you mean?
Matt, you guys make me laugh.
It might be because of Algonauts.
He's still making me laugh.
Do you even support him?
luck with the portal thank you phoenix okay up
oh oh
oh okay it's blue okay okay okay remember to use orange or
yeah well okay wait wait wait okay okay okay wait wait okay
okay okay wait Wait?
Yeah.
Oh, wait?
Okay.
Okay, wait.
We got this.
God, fucking first try.
All we had to do was wait.
Look at that.
We waited.
It didn't have to be like this.
I can open doors.
Please try, please try.
Holy shit.
It, whoa, my God, we don't even play in this game.
game for 50 minutes we've only played this game for 50
minutes and we're almost finished with this game is that
crazy chat only 50 minutes yeah don't don't trust nightbot
nightbot's being weird right now there's like a bug right
now with nightbot but it's only been 50 what's that no 50
out, let me out, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
Okay, I didn't, I, I didn't know, I didn't know.
Yeah, it's only been 50 minutes, yeah.
Okay, over here.
Over here?
over here Missile
Portal Portal Portal
Portal Yeah, you see that?
Portal Okay Is that an important level yet?
Okay.
What's a portal?
Never heard of a jam.
We can start for you.
What do you mean?
I'm trying my hardest.
Portal?
Cube?
Wait.
Cube.
Cube, cube, cube!
We got it!
We got cube!
Okay, we don't need this.
We don't need this.
Like, is it okay for you to be out in society at this stage?
Look, it's just, it's just portal.
It's just portal.
Portal.
Portal did this to me.
Portal?
It's just portal.
This is why I should not be doing...
This is why I don't do puzzle games, chat.
This is my brain on puzzles.
What?
Okay.
Portal is just an excuse.
What do you mean?
I swear.
Oh my god.
Look how fat this is.
natural speed run I'm speed running boys and girls I'm speed
run oh my god that's so fast oh my god I'm speed rating I
hate this the sound is disgusting this is just wait am I
supposed to portal oh I'm supposed to portal out here I'm
supposed to portal out here turrets wait what wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait no No, no tur- no I don't- I don't have
my cube
Wait, wait, how do I do this?
Okay, now I have my portal now I have my cubes now I have my
cubes chat
Now I'll use this guy
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
No!
Okay.
Okay, wait.
Wait.
No!
Wait, wait.
Can this block?
Can I do this?
Okay.
Look at that.
This is my...
What are you doing?
This is my cube now.
This is my cube.
I'm just using them to knock the others over.
Which one?
Who's next?
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait.
Wait, wait, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
Wait.
Oh.
Oh, is this right?
It's short.
Do you hear me?
Scary laugh?
It's looking...
Okay.
It's looking different than I remember.
No, wait, wait, wait.
Please give me, like, five minutes.
Give me five minutes, drone.
Please, please, please.
Don't shoot me.
Okay, there you go.
There you go.
We got this.
this we're very slowly like if i try to kill a spider i'm
just killing i'm just killing a spider real quick chat i'm
killing a spider with another spider okay i don't know what
happened but i'm having a good time okay okay okay all right
how many more spiders Do we have left?
Alright, two more.
Two more.
How do we get up there, though?
Oh, God.
This is...
What do you mean?
They're dying, aren't they?
They're dying.
That's all that matters.
It doesn't matter how we do this.
As long... As long as it's happening.
Oh, I hooked up.
Okay.
As long as this happens...
No!
Where did it go?
No, my spider!
Okay, it's okay.
I have a backup.
wait i need another one i fucked up i fucked up i need to
get another one we're gonna see i need to find another
spider okay then we have a backup backup don't worry we have
a backup backup okay you know what i'm just okay this is
more easy this is easier here we go Look at all Look at all
these Look at all these turrets Okay, this is the new one
Alright, where's the last one?
Last one's over there There you are Okay Look at the
massacre Alright Alright, we did it We did it It was not, oh
there's one There's one more?
Okay, which one's the new one Oh, you're kidding That we're
not using that, I guess.
Orange.
Alright.
Okay.
Look at that.
We did it.
Exterminate your donkey.
Alright.
I'm going to assume it's like this right where does this
take me oh wait what wait what wait what i'm so confused up
up okay oh up
Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait.
And then, oh!
Oh!
Okay, okay, I got this.
Okay, it's blue.
Blue, use blue.
And then, blue!
And then, okay, that's not it.
Okay, wait.
Alright.
Blue.
Wait, wait, wait, what?
Wait, blue.
Blue.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, I got this
chat, I got this, don't worry, my brain, my brain going
blue, orange, orange, orange, and then blue, and then
orange, orange, orange, orange, orange, orange, orange, and
then, ah, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay,
okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay,
okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay,
okay, okay, okay Blue.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Processing.
Orange.
Yeah, zero death.
Zero death.
We've not died once.
We have not died.
Not even once.
Blue.
And then...
No!
Wow!
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, orange, blue, okay.
How am I faking this up?
I understand.
Okay, orange.
Aren't you glad to see me?
Woo, okay.
Blue.
Okay, okay.
You died five times less just me than if I died zero, guys.
That means you have died zero.
Exactly, exactly.
Orange, blue, blue.
And then...
Orange!
Blue!
And oh... How did I fuck that up?
And...
And then...
Okay, no.
Okay, and then...
Yeah?
And then...
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah, you got this.
And then... Okay, no, no.
And then...
Wait, where the fuck am I?
Wait, where did I go?
Wait, wait a second.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait
It's gonna work, I swear Okay, alright, alright And then
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay And okay, wait, no, no, no, no,
this is it This is it, and then Okay, okay, alright, alright
Alright, alright, alright Alright, and then, and then Okay,
okay, okay, okay, okay This will work, okay, This is my,
okay, okay, okay This is, this is, I'm just practicing I'm
just practicing this isn't the real this isn't I'm just
practicing I'm practicing and then okay all right all right
it won't work I swear this is cool and then all right all
right all right and then all right and then all right and
then all right all right all right okay just practicing I'm
just practicing chat I'm just practicing here we go There we
go, there we go, there we go, and then, and then.
Boom!
And then...
No!
That could have been it.
Okay.
Alright.
all right i'm just practicing i'm just practicing chat let's
just practice we're gonna get it we're gonna get it boom and
then okay this wasn't it i'm practicing more okay all right
all right all right here we go here we go here we go here we
go here we go here we go here we go here we go we go.
All right.
Boom.
And then.
Oh my god.
I fucked it up again.
Okay.
When I get there.
I'm just practicing chat.
I'm just practicing.
What the fuck?
How do I do this?
Okay.
Wait, how do I get out of here?
And the orange, right?
No!
Oh, oh, blue.
Orange, orange, orange, orange, orange.
Wait, wait, wait, I got it!
I got it!
Okay, okay, okay.
Orange.
And then...
Oh, blue.
And...
Oh!
I told you, it was just a practice.
I was just practicing, guys.
Now I'm a pro.
Now I'm even better at... Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait.
I was just practicing.
Chat.
I had to practice my portal skills, you know?
Okay, how do I get out of here?
Look!
My FPS skills!
Look at me!
I'm head glitching!
My FPS skills led me to this!
To flex and get glitched!
Look at that.
Look at that, look at them flex.
Look it up.
Okay, I fucked up up.
I fucked up up.
I somehow fucked up, guys.
Okay, okay.
Oh, whoa, whoa!
Okay, let me need water.
I need water.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Can we do another up?
We can do another up.
Okay.
All right, up.
And then, and then- Fuph!
Okay, maybe this is not the right portal for up.
I was on Black Maria.
Thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
I have a butthart.
Oh, thank you so much.
Oh, have a butthart.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Maybe I need, um, maybe up here?
Up here.
Yes!
Up!
Up, up, up, up, up, up, up.
Okay.
Now down.
Down, down, down, down.
I always think when the original game is hot right now and
you you two?
I am?
You can just do old classics?
Okay.
Wait, where did I come from?
Oh, I came from here.
Right?
Yeah, yeah, because there's door.
Look, I'm bunny hopping.
I don't think this is actually bunny hopping.
But...
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Is this GLaDOS?
GLaDOS, is this you?
Look, are you proud of me?
Are you proud of me, Gladys?
I did it!
I went up!
Wait, more missiles?
Wait, is this a boss fight?
Wait.
Wait, oh no.
Oh no.
Wait, wait, wait.
That wasn't supposed to happen.
Do you see that thing that fell out of me?
What is that?
Wait, is this really?
Surprise.
I've never seen it before.
Where are you?
Are you really?
It's a mystery.
I'll solve later by myself because you'll be dead.
Are you the blue guy?
Where are you taking that thing?
Okay, but he's purple.
Where am I taking him?
I wouldn't bother with that thing.
My guess is that touching it will just make your life even
worse somehow.
Okay.
All right.
What do I do?
I don't want to tell you your business, but if it were me,
I'd leave that thing alone.
Oh.
What's it?
Do you think I'm trying to trick you with reverse
psychology?
I mean, seriously.
Button!
Okay, fine.
Do touch it.
Button, get it.
Let's be honest.
Neither one of us knows what that thing does.
Burn.
Don't put it in the corner and I'll deal with it later.
Okay, now...
Okay.
Probably some kind of raw sewage container.
Button good.
Portal, yes.
All right, button, button.
Maybe you should marry that thing since you love it so much.
Do you want to marry it?
Well, I won't let you.
How does that feel?
All right, button, button good.
Have I lied to you?
I mean, in this room.
Trust me, leave that thing alone.
All right, all right, all right, all right, come on.
Come on, come on.
No, no, whoa.
Really?
Okay, I just need to line it up.
Okay.
Oh, portal!
Button good, then portal good.
Portal.
And then...
Oh my gosh, I'm so smart.
I went.
I'm so smart.
Button good, and then portal good, and then burn good.
Okay.
There.
Oh my God, I'm still.
Oh my God, I did it.
I did it.
What it does into an aperture science emergency intelligence
incinerator that has got to be the dumbest thing.
It's negative right now with a single voice in.
I figured out what that thing you just incinerated.
It was a morality core they installed after I flooded the
enrichment center.
I'm back with one human legend, Matt.
Welcome back, Siri.
Wait, we're just doing the final, the final, final boss
fight.
I thought they were, they were, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, oh, oh my god, oh, wait.
What's this?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, I really
appreciate it.
Thank you so much!
What?
Hey!
Oh, I missed.
I missed!
I fucking missed!
I can't!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, where is this lead?
Wait.
Wait, I missed again!
Definitely missed Okay, wait wait wait wait is this how do I
keep missing?
Okay, I'm just gonna go here.
Okay, all right.
All right, is this wait where is she?
Where even is she?
Oh Oh gas will kill me if I take too long.
Oh no, wait is this is this her?
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Wait, wait.
Is it?
Yes.
I love you I did!
Geometry!
I did it!
Wait, button?
Button?
What was that?
Did you say something?
I sincerely hope you weren't expecting a response.
What's it?
Because I'm not talking to you.
The talking is over.
But, get the spear?
Spear?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay,
what's in, but, okay, don't worry, don't worry, don't worry,
don't worry, don't worry, don't worry, don't worry, don't
worry, I'm gonna press button.
I'm gonna press button.
No, don't you dare Button Oh, he even fell clearly.
I'm three minutes Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Okay, geometry geometry, geometry, geometry, geometry I got
this.
I got this.
Look at this.
Look at this chat.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, no, no, don't move.
Don't move.
Don't move, don't move, don't move, don't move, yes!
Oh, Paul?
Paul?
Wait, Paul!
Two minutes, Paul!
Where's Paul?
Paul!
Where are you?
There's still something burning!
Where's Paul?
On top?
Top?
Top.
Top, top, top.
Wait.
How do you get top?
How do we get top?
How do we go up?
Up.
And two minutes.
Portal.
No, wrong up.
Wrong up.
Portal.
Okay.
I'm trying to figure this out Oh no No
Wait how much should I do I left Two minutes, two minutes,
two minutes Okay Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay Okay, okay
Okay, okay, okay, okay Guys, I don't do well under pressure
I don't do well under pressure, guys I don't do I don't do
well under pressure guys i don't don't i don't do well under
pressure guys i don't do well under pressure i don't do well
under pressure okay okay okay okay no no no please please
please i don't do well under pressure please wait i up wait
okay one minute one minute one minute okay okay
I don't do well.
I don't do well under pressure.
I don't do well under pressure Ah, no, my god, I just picked
this up No, oh 40 oh 40 seconds please please Please do well
Please, please I don't do well Please just die.
No, please Wait, don't do this.
25 seconds, 25 seconds, 20 seconds.
No, no, no.
Ah, oh, yes.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Oh, 30 seconds.
Oh, Paul, Paul.
Paul, Paul, Paul, Paul.
Wait, where's Paul?
Where's Paul?
Paul, come down.
Bob
Bob I'm dead I'm so sad I'm fantastic Okay, okay, okay now I
know Now I know chat Now I know I can't fuck up now Wait, I
fucked up Wait, I still...
Wait, I fucked up.
Wait, I still fucked up.
Okay, I can't fuck up now.
I can't fuck up now.
I can't...
Wait, rocket.
Rocket, rocket, rocket, rocket.
Rocket, rocket.
Rocket.
Oh my god, rocket.
Okay.
Okay, I can't fuck up.
I can't fuck up now.
Okay, okay, I got this.
I got this memorized.
Okay.
Rocket game.
I can't fuck up.
I didn't get...
Please.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Okay, now I can't fuck up.
I can't fuck up now.
I can't fuck up now, please, please, please Orange, orange,
orange, please Please, I can't fuck up, I can't fuck up
Wait, wait, I fucked up, wait, how did I fuck up?
Wait, how did I fuck up?
Wait, wait, okay, I can't fuck up Wait, I fucked up, wait
I can't fuck up.
I can't- why can't- okay.
Okay, I'm fucking up.
Okay, Chad, I'm fucking up.
I'm fucking up.
I'm fucking up right now.
I'm so excited.
Thank you so much.
How am I fucking up?
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Okay, okay, there we go.
Okay, guys, some pro- okay.
There we go.
I couldn't fuck up.
What?
How did it?
How?
Please, please, please, how?
I'm fucking up.
I'm fucking up, chat.
How am I fucking up?
Okay, can't dodge this.
She can't dodge this.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, blue, blue orange, blue, no, wait,
blue, orange, wait, wait, where?
Blue, blue, blue, orange, blue, orange, blue, oh, I can't
fuck out.
I'm afraid my neighbor, I don't know what I'm doing.
I don't know what's going on anymore.
Okay.
I can't fuck up.
There's no way.
Okay.
Bye.
Alright.
Up.
Okay.
Two minutes.
I have two minutes.
Okay.
Blue.
Orange!
Are you?
Oh, I can't fucking game!
Oh, under?
Under?
Wait, under works?
Under works.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh!
What?
No!
Under no work!
No, no, no, no!
I'm fucking up!
Wait, I'm fucking up!
No!
I'm fucking up!
I don't work under pressure.
I'm gonna work well under pressure.
I don't work well under pressure.
Please.
How?
How are you dodging this?
Please.
Shoot me.
Wait.
Okay.
Please.
Two minutes.
I'm not throwing.
I'm actually not throwing.
How is she touching us?
She's touching us.
She's touching us This one I'm not looking up.
She's dodging my fucking thing.
She's touched it How how is she dodging this?
How is she dodging it?
I have 40 seconds, please Please please please please please
Okay, okay.
Oh, um Up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up,
up.
Up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up.
Wait, how do I do this?
How do I do this?
I'm picking up, I'm picking up, I'm picking up, I'm picking
up.
I'm picking up, how, how?
How, how?
How?
Please, how chat.
How, how?
How?
How am I?
Please!
No!
How?
Okay.
Okay, okay, speed run.
Okay, speed run.
Speed run.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
No dodge, no dodge.
No dodge.
How are you dodging this?
Okay, slow and steady.
Slow and steady.
Yes.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
How are you dodging this?
How the fuck are you dodging this?
I don't understand.
I use social to follow us.
Thank you so much for following us.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
How?
What the fuck?
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, slow and steady.
Slow and steady wins the race.
Slow and steady.
Okay, alright.
Slow and steady wins the race.
race slow and steady wins the race slow and steady wins the
race slow and steady wins the race okay there's going to be
a lot less conversation all right okay okay you're doing
some damage wait wait maybe unless wait wait wait This angle
this angle this angle this angle this angle this is good
angle right this is good angle, right?
This is this is not good angle this is oh this is good
angle, right?
Oh, oh this is good.
Oh, this is good angle.
This is good angle.
This is it.
This is the one.
I fucking I fucking give up.
I fucking give up.
We're just using this angle This is the angle that we're
gonna use.
This is the angle that we're gonna use Here we go.
This is the angle.
This is how are you dodging this?
How?
How are you dodging this?
Oh my
Oh my god, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, here we go, here we
go, blue, blue, blue, okay, wait, over here, blue, blue,
blue, blue, where, blue, blue, where, blue, blue, okay,
okay, slow and steady, we have three minutes, slow and
steady, slow and steady, what's the race, slow and steady,
when's the race?
Slow it!
Where did he go?
Where did he?
Wait, bro, he went in!
Really?
Okay, okay.
I was like, where did he go?
Okay, okay, okay.
He helped me, he fucking, he felt bad for me.
He felt bad for me that he went in the portal.
How are you fucking dodging this?
Okay, okay two minutes two minutes slow and steady slow it's
oh, this is not angled right this is not angled right.
Oh, wait, wait, I lied I lied, I lied So in blue purple
orange orange.
I got you.
Oh You thought you thought you thought you thought where are
you?
Yes, yes, yes Yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo Yo,
yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo,
yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo,
yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo We did it.
We did it.
Zero deaths.
Oh.
Zero.
Zero deaths.
Zero death.
It only took us an hour to finish this game chat.
It only took us an hour.
Isn't that insane?
It only don't don't mind I bought and I bought some broken
right now, but it only took us an hour To finish portal.
We're so good
It's only took you an hour to be
Oh my god We did it We do it for all record rounds.
Oh my god.
Oh, we did it.
We did it chat.
Whatever I did join it on.
Dude, I'm a fucking mess right now.
I'm a fucking mess.
Look, there it is.
There's the cake.
oh there it is we did it my birthday happy birthday I'm
great actually I actually have tears in my eyes I actually
have tears in my eyes guys this this took me so much this
kid took me so fucking long oh my Oh my god, I actually have
tears running down right now.
Oh my god.
Oh.
My thirsting.
I mean, you're straight.
This happens.
Oh my god.
We're looking bad.
We did it.
We did it!
What a great first shape!
Just because I got it!
Oh no, Christine!
There's the happiest!
No more up!
No more portal!
I showed up on the wrong time!
Oh!
No more portal!
No more up!
I feel better than I was I swear to you, I can't believe it
only took you 10 minutes.
This took me, chat, this only took me 15 minutes to beat
this.
That's crazy.
First try, ew.
She's so worried, we're sitting over so fast.
Oh my God, I'm like wiping tears right now.
Chat, my hat tracker's wiping tears out of my eyes right
now.
Oh my god.
We did it.
Oh my god, we did it.
I'm making trackers broken because I'm crying.
I'm making models broken because I'm crying tears of
happiness right now.
Oh my god.
We did it.
Holy shit, chat.
If we eat the neighbors, she didn't use the herni-superior
cube.
We're gonna have to- Oh my god, no, I have to cry.
Oh my god, no, I have crying.
Where's my cry?
Oh.
It's so alive.
I feel fantastic.
No.
please please i've been through so much i've been through so
much guys i've been through so much chat we did it
oh congratulations we did it